[Music]
to cluster fasting is the pitch it's you
inside Andy samberg's stomach wanted
where this is cluster huh
[Music]
but in this place
plus the fast I get it so you to think
so you might
[Music]
you experience Action Bronson Bert
Kreischer Ali Siddiq Ando voice if so
ask your doctor if cluster fest is right
for you
rare that serious reactions could occur
such as Josh Johnson let's podcast on
left analingus Michelle Collins Sam J
asparagus pee Shan Torres and Tim Dillon
some patients experience low but not
insignificant sexual side effects Lester
Fest is habit-forming with guaranteed
sexual side effects low say is your day
won't work don't be shy ask your doctor
about cluster fest the number one brand
[Music]
she has
you're wearing a brown nope don't need
one next question
there's nothing I love more than nothing
that makes sense you know I like more
than anything
hi I'm Kyle sexes step into the world of
your favorite companies
[Music]
[Applause]
The Daily Show presents the Donald J
Trump residential Twitter library have a
drink in Paddy's Pub ding-dong call
Teresa Scala and we'll see you at buster
[Music]
there's no way we're just in that white
room right not a beautiful we are not
there we are here